dear little Mariah you're a wonderful
one-of-a-kind wonder I know you may not
feel that way right now because you
don't have a quote normal name like
Katie or Julie and most people don't
even know how to pronounce Mariah though
it's not even that hard I know a lot of
people put you down because of your
clothes your house your hair and try to
make you feel other that they are better
than you and you are a less of who you
are but I want to tell you this truth no
matter what things look like now you are
worthy and deserving of all the
attention love protection care
conditioner and fancy dresses in the
whole wide world I'm so proud of how you
have held on to your faith that song
lyric out of make it happen no matter
what and because of your faith and pure
heart you will move past the mean people
and get through the scary stuff and
we'll grow up to have more than you or
anyone could ever imagine and you will
spread the spirit of Christmas all over
the land
for all of Time Love Mariah oh this is
actually important
PS multitudes of people will not only
know how to pronounce your name because
it was very Mario oh here you know
someone's a
um they will actually name little girls
after you
[Music]